Across Cameroon the level of unemployment
is around 30 percent.
Some analysts believe the real figure is much higher.
Many people have to take on informal jobs
like motor taxi driving to make ends meet.
Even highly skilled workers like Sakwe Njayo
have problems finding a real job.
“You are just from High school or any professional
school and did internship for like three months
but you are still looking for a job.”
The job market in Cameroon is complicated.
Workers and entrepreneurs can't establish contact easily.
That's why start-up founder Churchill Mambe
Nanje had to find a solution.
“It was very difficult for me to find new
developers.
So I thought it wise that if I build a platform
where there would be a database of profiles
that I could search through, that's what led
me to njorku.com.“
In 2012 he created a job page named
njorku.com -
with massive success. It is now among Africa’s
biggest job search engines.
“Njorku is an aggregator just like Google.
So we go to other job sites and other websites
and find jobs and career pages of companies
then aggregate job content and bring it in
one location.”
Churchill collects job adverts from other
job sites and puts them on Njorku.
Two hundred thousand people search for jobs
each month and over 2 million job records
can be found on Njorku.
Software engineers like Sakwe Njayo use the
website to upload their resumees.
“When I tell someone that I studied in India
they raise their eyebrows in surprise, and
the next question that comes out is how much?”
Skilled workers expect higher wages and this
is another reason why unemployment remains
high and is a big challenge for families in Cameroon.
“When they are not working after spending
so much money on them, they come back home
and sit in the house and you keep feeding
and clothing them and even providing them
with to money to go and search the internet
for jobs.
So it’s really a burden to all the parents.”
But Njorku.com still is a success and brings
together employees and businessmen.
Even if Churchill Mambe Nanje struggles
with the same problems as the workers do:
lack of money.
“You need to pay them well so they don’t
move to bigger companies that will pay them higher.
You need to motivate them.
What we do here is helping hundreds of thousands
of people.
But that’s not enough.
You need also to pay them a reasonable package
a month so that they stay.”
For Churchill Nanje, njorku.com is a mission.
He wants to create opportunities for others and
hopes that other developers will follow his footsteps.